[Music]  it's way out  [Music]  why whatever trait we all have our  secrets  we just didn't get to yours yet  the world is arming faster than we can  respond  where's double-oh-seven I need a favor  brother you're the only one I trust for  this  the world's moved on commander bond you  would go below two years so stay in your  lane you get in my way I will put a  bullet in your knee  that's what you do would get along name  bond  James Bond so you're not dead hello Q  I've missed you  it's the most valuable asset this  country has if you feel yourself losing  control I'm not going to lose  control  James you gave up everything for her  when her secret finds its way out  they'll be the death of him what is it  you don't know what this is James Bond  license to kid history of violence I  could be speaking to my own reflection  only your skills die with her body  mine was survived long after I'm gone  history isn't kind to men who play God  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]